in taste the 25th of September all right
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcasts for
Monday
they say podcast podcasts for Monday
September 25th 2017 what's going on how
are you what's up I am back from Toronto
Canada and every once in a while every
once in a long while I have a I have a
guest and I always get good guests and
this is no today is no exception we have
the great Felipe Esparza on here who has
a welcome first of all welcome they've
had me was so full there you go
Felipe Esparza from the what's up move
podcast and let's get all the hype out
of the way at first we got you have a
new HBO special yes a new HBO special on
September 30 at 10:00 September 30th at
10:00 on HBO that's where the HBO
specials are called translate this so
let's get into it
tell me about that wasn't like to shoot
a hour-long special for HBO it was it
was good I shot it myself I I am I got
the money together I stayed up some
money and my wife and I we we chose San
Jose improv and we got cloud shires
uh-huh and it was all DIY you know so
you did it yourself an HBO liked it so
much they bought it all so when you were
doing it you weren't thinking like holy
[ __ ] I'm doing an HBO special don't know
where it's gonna go they open lots of
Netflix somewhere Amazon no but that's I
think that's a that's a great way to
done how the [ __ ] is nobody giving you a
shot I don't know you know why you're
not white like me I gotta be honest
before we I did this you know I always
look up like videos and all that type of
stuff to make sure I got something to
talk about so it doesn't become this
like my biggest fear with these
interviews is it's just gonna become
this horrific staring contest because
I'm such a huge fan of what you do and I
had never seen the the Irishman when Ari
Shaffir was hosting the show this isn't
happening
yeah when you told that whole story
about being in the gang and fighting the
guy fight in his ear off and Shea's just
like like I was listening that that
story it was like this is like at least
three
from Tarantino movies ha and then he you
ended it in just such a nice place I
don't want to force you to tell the
story again but if you could just recap
my um start bite where did you grow up I
grew up in um Boyle Heights California
you know
Los Angeles but easterly let's call
Boyle Heights you know East LA is like
further east East and Los Angeles you
know it's by almost close to Monterey
Park but Boyle Heights is the
neighborhood how far away is that to put
it in white perspective how far away is
that from the Staples Center ooh
if I were to walk they'll take me that
an hour and now if you were to drive
probably 50 minutes within minutes okay
cool
a 30 minute bus ride okay 30 minute bus
ride so you grow up what you what what
decade you're a child of what you
Kaylee's you're the eighties I grew up
in the 80s so that was the real deal
yeah I grew up when my neighborhood was
in the housing projects Pico Gardens and
there was like three separate housing
project it was a little village Pico
alley so and then Pico Gardens from
first Street to like sixth Street okay
and it was like [ __ ] meadow like a
shitload of gangs like maybe 11 how did
you know when you're not in a gang and
you're a young kid how do you negotiate
like I gotta get from my house I gotta
go pick up my [ __ ] I gotta go do my
laundry I got to go to school how do you
negotiate is it now a gangs 24/7 oh yeah
man they're 25 neighborhood there were
24/7
yeah I I always thought they came out
around 5:00 like anybody was like just
living the regular lifestyle goes to bed
and then they just kind of give up this
the area there and then those gangs they
come on at 5:00
they're like the gang that there are
still living in a gentrified
neighborhood okay hit oh come on a date
ugh they might call the cops on them oh
yeah member most gagging you know from
Echo Park they come out at night man
robbing people really yeah they come out
at night
those guys were we were the
justification those gangs are still
around but they come out at night and
the gang bang at different areas you
know but there's still gang bang in
there
it'll happen how old were you the first
time you got mugged
I got mugged on the first time when I
was like 18 years old my friend I'm Coco
that's pretty good man yeah I got 18
Downtown Crossing when I was like in
eighth grade then I was like I was
selling crack on my first day like that
with a 1-hour where I got robbed
somebody put a knife behind my back
another knife in might like in front of
me and they took all my my crack away
took on you crack away so yeah then what
do you have to do I have to go back to
the guy who gave it to me a friend of
mine who I grew up with you know he
passed away already
I used to call him Coco uh-huh and we
grew up together him and I were from
second grade two adults I needed money
at the time I got somebody pregnant and
I didn't know how to make money so I
asked him for a job in the criminal
business you know how does that go down
you probably know avoid it it's like I
don't want to sell drugs but I kind of
have to now I got a kid coming so help
me so he gave me like a hundred dollars
of crack you know 100 to just bring me
back a hundred then I give you more to
sell so as soon as I got out they didn't
know who I was in that neighborhood they
just came around me and he took all my
stuff then it hurt me or anything I was
begging for my just gonna keep my ID and
they gave my ID all I did how scared we
I was scared man I thought they were
gonna kill me right there I was I felt
like I was young I was really scared but
I'll calm you know I wasn't like uh-uh
all right just take him and just take
you leave me alone you know I just
walked out I take it I didn't fight him
or nothing
cuz I know they would have killed me or
stab me and worse so went back to my
friend Coco and I told him what happened
and I thought you know he was gonna be
okay man you know it's all right it's
your foot it happens happens
no man that night escalated like it took
with it he gave me the crack and I
caught me midnight I got robbed about
1:30 at 2:30 in the morning I'm back at
his house what who robbed your cars so
what happened he gave me a gun he gave
me this stuff right he got himself a
pistol and he put a blue handkerchief on
his head
and he put a black beanie on and we both
went looking for a little guys and you
must have been praying to God like I
don't want to murder somebody the first
oh hell yeah I'm out there please don't
find it wise Wow because like there I
was like I would probably was done
anything he would have told me I was
vulnerable I was weak
right you know I have no I don't know
what to do so we went together and we
saw one guy that saw what happened but
he didn't do anything and and then like
he kind of like hit him real hard and
who did it man well yet then I said man
I wasn't here man within him
so they wasn't him wait how did that it
so you hold I think I remember that guy
standing there watching me get robbed so
now this poor bastard gets dragged into
it he gets dragged into anything you got
like he got a gun slap you know but my
friend he's my friend leaving that's a
little question he just hit him in a
faith hard man and like I believe I'm a
deer and I just say wow man he was look
at every like come on man please tell
him it wasn't me so you waited till
after the pistol slap
I meant meant to tell you this it wasn't
him so we got nothing happened to him
and we went back and later on those guys
who actually did it walk back and gave
it back or everything get back to crack
to that guy and everything was cool
that's what he has there sorry we don't
know that they were afraid of that guy
yes sir we don't know Batman were with
you yeah we should street nickname yeah
so then after that then they knew that
you were with him so then people stop
[ __ ] with you people thought messing
with me yeah Jesus Christ this is what
kills me about you is you have like a
thousand of those stories and you're the
most relaxed laid-back guy ever like
where did it all go cuz dude I look at
me I I sound like I lived your life and
you sound like you live my life like you
sound like you grew up in a nice little
cul-de-sac area and played street hockey
and I'm all [ __ ] wound up how did you
do that well I have a mama I have
parents I have my mom and dad and most
of my crazy friends in the projects you
know the crazier ones didn't have a mom
and dad alright they had nobody telling
him you better come home early or there
was nobody telling those kids to come
home and the lights go on in the streets
so they had no really nobody telling
them what to do how to live right
Blin I have my mom and dad I'm that word
and my mom stood on my worked at a
elementary school like be home from
selling crack when the street lights
came on right yeah oh is that Family
Foundation but I've always out but I
don't get that I just now you're talking
at our home life but you're telling you
you're doing all this other [ __ ] no the
kid you know when I was like 13 12 14
years old I wasn't crazy oh I got crazy
after high school I got someone pregnant
he didn't know what to do but I was
always like a little hustler man my mom
who saw Avon and I would collect the
money for her you know so I learned how
to collect money for people at least for
my mom was always telling her Herbalife
Avon
she was only selling something so we
live by the warehouses in downtown LA
where the factories are at where other
trucks would come in and pick up stuff
on the trains and take him to like
stores so my mom knew were like we used
to go to his one factory and we wish to
UM put a bunch of that synthetic cotton
the plastic one they would throw it away
my mom and I were put in bags like hefty
bags mm-hmm and then we go to another
place where they would throw these
raggedy old sheets and then my mom was
so those raggedy old sheets with the
cotton and in Wardour Adele door the
door in a housing project styling
pillows so you guys were a real green
family man you were there you were there
recycling that we saw before the trash
and we slowly like we saw pillows I used
to when I was like 14 I used to walk to
downtown you do with pallets would you
build a little house and then sell that
no man that that's too much work I want
we want fast money
oh okay ash other was a bunch of
factories where I live you know I felt
like I felt like Henry hero from
Goodfellas right because they were
always stealing stuff from the airport
and we're always taking stuff from these
factories
I wasn't stealing from these factories
my friends were I was taking stuff in
the trash like um no there was a
watermelon factory and they will throw
away rotten watermelons and I will get
the watermelons and clever man
watermelon like they make water but you
know they grew them know that they will
get them from the farmer against Andy
right they would hold them there they
have pallets full of watermelon from so
there's like a grocery area of downtown
LA where every grocer out gets all this
other stuff flowers stereos you know you
name it piñatas I know where everything
is that suits you cheap suits I don't
know where things that so we'll get the
hang out and just go to the dumpsters
and whenever they threw out you would
then go sell yeah I will cut that
watermelon in half and then go sell it
to the Mexicans day laborers everybody
that working in the factories much a
bunch of immigrants right and I saw the
half a watermelon for a dollar two
dollars five I would just cut the rotted
piece off you know I mean or it wants to
know why nobody's looking I was saying
my little home girl this girl this
little less while she the lesbian now
but we don't know she was a lesbian now
she was a tomboy right I was sent her in
there with my brother they were it was
like whenever nobody was looking it
would throw good water man in a trash
can - so we're gonna make sure of good
and bad water - how long did you stay in
that whole world is selling crack and
all of that and all those fights and
biting the guy's ear off and all that
[ __ ] before you became a comedian like
how long how long was that period you
like that was my period from 18 years
old to like 21 and a half 21 and a half
because that 21 is when I was like
messing up already man I was like I'm
smoking a lot of PCP I was like my drug
of choice for the time being and when I
have to get off vcpr I think it's a
elephant tranquilizer that's what people
tell me
ice always here that grown a PCP angel
dust and all and yeah angel angel does
that like come and crystallized PCP you
could put in a cigarette but PCP in my
neighborhood we were at the PCP capital
of the Los Angeles like in my
neighborhood they sold gallons of it
people had to they wouldn't have our
sparklers water full of PCP so everybody
had PCP wait a minute you could hide you
ingested you smoked it no you did a girl
I'm giving away secrets here I'll tell
you I'm asking cuz everybody tries to
act like understand I'll know ma'am a
boozehound I don't know any that stay
you will get a newport cigarette
probably a menthol cigarette a Newport
and then you put you or you and you dip
it instead like a little jar like um
just a tip and there's a $5 tip that's a
$5 dip you dip it again at ten you dip a
whole one is twenty you know you you you
soak it as thirty dollars and it's by
tip you know now I get it that's like
when I drink booze there's like a
ten-year-old [ __ ] that you're Ollie up
to 25 then you get into the cognac and
they can be like I don't know like the
fine wines and [ __ ] could be like a
century or old or something so this one
night I'm smoking PCP playing it just
because I'm stupid as hell when it comes
here so what is it what's that high like
it's all man it's like you didn't quit
about Hulk if somebody attacks you oh
this is a [ __ ] when like five cops show
up and they got five more did you see
that Chuck Bronson movie this was three
when yeah one white boy like the surfer
he's been he's fighting all the police
officers
he's on PCP okay I got a rewatch that
yeah I'm a PCB King you think you have
um like incredible whole strength but
you just have like more you don't feel
pain but while people are hitting you
man you could just keep attacking
forever you know I mean right and then
the next morning you wake up and you
feel like you played 12 years in the NFL
yeah man
all right so the first time you smoked
PCP and that [ __ ] hits you it's like
literally like you're turning into like
a superhero yeah man well the one time
what did you do did you try to bend
something no cops no no I want to try to
pull something off the [ __ ] wall
I've been together ona well that when I
was like walking around I was becoming
to be knowing that Batman you know he's
crazy watch out for him why did they
call you why did they call you Batman
cuz um I love Batman and a nice to wear
my clothes I'm the superhero on the
rules
uh-huh and 18 yeah Master well the
Batman shirts still fit so I wore it and
then I don't know where to get a Batman
shirt anywhere else was the underoos
factory right down the street
Oh get out of the
to the back projects yeah that's amazing
all right so you're doing all that I'm
watching um I'm at the drive-in theater
with my friends smoking PCP watching
Terminator 2 asking why I'm saying I'd
fight that guy yeah man and I don't
thinking about the guy that had bullied
me for the last two weeks so I go no
wait if you smoke that say say a guy
view is I shouldn't do this because I'm
like doing a commercial here for the
drug saying there's somebody bullying
you you can't beat that guy right if you
were to smoke some peat PCP it
definitely gives you the belief but can
it overcome how slow you are on your
inability to slip a punch and all you
just walk through his [ __ ]
yeah man you're throwing punches because
um when I when I got into a fight with
this guy I was they told me I was doing
things that I remember doing I think
they told me that took my belt off and
I'm whipping them all over though right
yeah we keep alluding to the story you
gotta tell the story right see you're
Batman you got on your underoos you
smoked PCP at the drive-in
you saw the Terminator - when I left the
Terminator - movie I come back in a
project and I see this guy that he lays
like an old dude man he's like 30 years
old he just came out of prison you don't
know who I am
he's like calling me bad names and
pushing me and pushing me and I want to
fight him pushing me then finally I
socked him in the face but I kind of
missed then he hit me right in the eye
and he hit me hard and I got black right
away he punched me in the face I started
bleeding
they started choking me so when I
started choking me that's when I like
got while we're crazy I went crazy man I
didn't see him up dropped him baby I bit
his ear off first of all been turned
into the home a bit easier up man like
the whole Cobra tell your brother let me
ask you this when you bit his ear off we
were underneath are you on top of him
how would I underneath him he was
choking me
and you just all of a sudden that PCP
calculated off man I never thought my
skin is so low easy to bite off and yeah
well I spin crochet I just know not even
man I spit it out and I started punching
him and then my friends told me that uh
wait what did he do
oh man took the hits like a soldier so
when you bet his ear off this guy
he's screaming like a little girl okay
didn't pain so actually he's kind of
screaming like a guy who got his ear bit
off yeah at that point I think you're
still a man if you if you go up a few
octaves when you're missing a [ __ ]
hear but I don't know why I bit his ear
up mean I had no I guess I had no choice
you know he was choking me sounded like
that was the move no one would help in
me he wasn't didn't seem like he was
gonna be stopping alright see you beat
it yeah then you took your belt off and
you were my friends told me that I took
it my belt off and I thought I did
whipping him like he was like chasing
them with about whipping them like like
he was like a runaway property or
something and how many people are
witnessing this I think that twelve
fifteen people but they're all I cheer
me on
cheering here Mara nobody's helping Dean
how many hits that would get like
nowadays if they were dude that would
that would be like it would be epic PCP
guy epic belt guy that'd be something
like that I would have been a rap song
auto-tune Batman yeah
so wait a minute so when you so you
don't remember doing that so that was
like all [ __ ] this guy's gonna kill me
then you start to bite his ear off
you're like wow ears come off really
easily then you sort of black out and
then like well you just sort of came to
with like blood all over you going like
lettuce eat a hotdog or something yeah
the next day I wake the next day I'm
walking around
it's like Ted it's 7:00 in the morning
8:00 in the morning I don't know man I'm
looking at my body it's full of blood my
pants my face you know my have a black
guy my shirt is full of blood I have no
idea what happened I have no idea what
happened you probably thought it was
your blood
yeah why I don't know that whoa no I was
like checking Steve got shot or stabbed
by somebody didn't know then my friends
told me what happened and that guy was
in a hot he went to the hospital for
like a broken ribs among here missing
ear you know what I just put Neosporin
on that house and they went to it he was
laying in bed and they asked him if do
you want to press charges you know cuz
everybody know there was witnesses
everybody knew who did it and he said no
we're gonna handle the right way
you know I didn't even know know this
until later on like a week later yeah
man I think there's like a green light
on you right now and you mean like green
light what do you mean green light yeah
man
shoot to kill they see you what the [ __ ]
so that's the first time you ever heard
that so now what now what do you do
besides not go outside do they know
where you live they know where I live
but I don't know what he's doing a
hospital though but everything's calm
you know but he's doing a hospital but I
could feel tension from people who are
who I thought were my friend at one time
what who I grew up with you know you
know they were turning on me like when
they were in their gang I was in another
gang when you watch the wire do you like
fall asleep is it like boring to you
because I watch the wire you don't need
to you live in it that's what I'm saying
like it sounds like an award-winning
series to me I'm more like blood in
blood out so wait a minute so now
there's a green light on you yeah and
okay at some point you got to go outside
to get food because you're hungry yeah
so I'm good when you have a green light
on you in in East LA what's a good time
to go out if you gotta go hit hit the
mayfair market or whatever what's wrong
man I don't thing to go to do right when
you know when you have a green light and
any enough from anybody you know whether
it comes from prison or wherever it
comes from just the neighborhood it's
just relieve man move somewhere safe
like Modesto what's the more serious
green light if it came from prisoner
from the neighborhood of a man if it
come from prison you're a dead man man I
mean there's nowhere to go there's
nowhere to go man and um I read about
these things you know outside of it on
books there's nobody coming back from
that but there was like only like a
green light from his neighborhood you
know let's go to the mall no I'd like
the grove pick a really white mall and
you know what all those thoughts came to
my mind at that time like man I wish I
was like the French Prince of bel-air
rich white guy to take a rich white guy
or a rich [ __ ] Mexican guy oh no way
they weren't were on that show that was
different strokes those difference
drummin drummin they switched it up
they're like it's different strokes
except America right now
yeah that's what they are with anything
always do that [ __ ] so my mom called our
father Greg Boyle he's like this priest
that I grew up with in the neighborhood
he's from the homeboy industries here in
LA that's a thing yeah he helps he up
some gang members that's a cool name
well the great Boyle he's like a priest
from my neighborhood and um he's always
helped the neighborhood like he would go
out his way to help people he was like
if he's like driving and then you like
he will pick up kids that were drunk off
the streets and take him home he did
that a couple of times for me in a good
way in a good way yeah like if you're a
gang member in the wrong neighborhood
and then you know you're pretty much
someone's gonna kill you in that
neighborhood for the great boy will tell
you get in a band I'll take you back
home as a as a gang member how do you
end up in the wrong neighborhood other
than a woman oh man on PCP
oh they're goddamn pieces there's no
heroin in your neighborhood so now you
got by heroin somewhere else you know
there's no crack in the neighborhood you
know it's a dry spell somewhere and you
got to get high so you gotta go to
another neighborhood and buy it oh oh
you have an aunt so how do they know
you're in a different gang you don't go
over there wearing your whole your
colors oh man though the most of the the
hardcore gang members they were the
colors man they make enough stop wearing
their colors yeah boy they're not
undercover there 24/7 but I wasn't one I
wouldn't want even one of those guys I
was nothing like that I was just a guy
who was just hanging around with these
kids then one day I get jumped into a
gang and I'm getting to oh so much
trouble but I don't know ideas to get
beaten into a gang just in case I ever
[ __ ] my life up and I go to prison you
know or I go to prison my only hope is I
gotta join the Aryan not see guys like
it another [ __ ] pretend I believe it
just to save myself how long is that
beatdown
well in in the streets it would be like
I guess whatever number the gang is over
18th Street you're gonna get beat up for
18 seconds that's it yeah
or but I mean how many guys all over
oh Jesus okay [ __ ] okay strike think
that's it from the record there because
when I got jumped in I was just hanging
out man like I was just hanging out and
then somebody stay down a man you're
gonna get jumped in and I wasn't gonna
say no if I say no I'm a punk I'm gonna
get jumped in I'm gonna get jumped for
being a punk so I said [ __ ] let's do
it and then I punch the guy next to me
for no reason
well because I want to prove that I'm
tough so the guy next to my just knocked
him out with one punch man
and then I hit like he wasn't even
looking I say let's do this and then
like I hit him back you know you gotta
be ready Big Dawg you gotta look out
homie that set warrants at MoMA
keep your head on a swivel I better get
the other guy's [ __ ] later like okay
next time we gonna jump somebody in can
you not say it what I'm sitting right
next to you knew he was a lefty what the
[ __ ] yeah you get beat up man and I got
jumped by everybody that dose you get
one in and you get more than one in you
get one I got two in one him and another
guy but then after that I felt like Nike
cortex all over my face so you just
laying on the ground and you just going
1 Mississippi 2 we're just waiting for
this rain of footlocker to stop coming
down on you yeah man it was like I
thought never gonna stop man so what do
you do I would just other funny they
start all right here enough hit enough
then everybody's hugging me the same
people that were beating my brains up
we're hugging me and kiss me you know I
love you you're my boy you're my family
now and then I Wow so then you come home
okay and then you're just sitting there
all right with [ __ ] sneaker marks all
over you and you're going like okay now
I guess I'm in a gang Jesus Christ okay
so then what happens I thought it what
happened was I thought of hanging you
know and white people talk about white
privilege go do what the [ __ ] is that
this is what it is totally yes it's it
they're selling lemonade at the end of
your driveway and they accidentally did
I just join a gang there was there's a
green light on you you were selling
lemonade
at the end of the wrong driveway you're
in the wrong neighborhood oh that was
dumb but you know like there was two
white boys in my neighborhood that were
gangs was one the redheaded kid from
children of the corn
exactly he was he was his what one guy
he was a blood Alec I he was from East
LA it's no mana column okay though
there's actually two white boy if I had
a fence if by the way but continue there
was two white boys in the hood man and
they were both gangbangers and one thing
about white boys all it was like when
you see a white boy join a gang and when
you see a white guy like someone like
you and you're hanging around with
nothing but Mexicans they're white white
guys are the most craziest gangsters
when they were in a Mexican gang they do
stuff that a Mexican man will never
think of like I remember this one white
guy snowman he was a blood he said man
let's go do a home invasion and then
everybody was asking him where he goes
my mom house oh he wanted a home game
all right
he wanted them he wanted eyebrows all
the homies to rob his house because he
want his mom and dad to you robbed why
cuz I don't know man they're probably
saying stop hanging out with all those
Mexicans probably Meadows idea hello
like dang so they probably behaved that
way because they felt no matter what
they they had to constantly prove
constantly men because technically they
could just get a haircut or whatever put
away the flannel and just slip slip away
slip away down at the Grove
step away become a social worker and
that'll be it so how long were you in
this gang for and did you ever get
beaten out no I was in this get to I'm
for the great boat when I bet that guy's
ear off I went to rehab my father Greg
Boyle took me to rehab and I disappeared
for I'm still gone I never went back
oh you never went back oh yeah when you
get beaten out of a gang how how long is
that beat them as long as they want to I
know we had a guy in the podcast named
Fabian who was in a gang and he talked
about he got beat up beat out he got
jumped out and he said that when he got
jumped it just last longer
but I'm his uncle it's doing the gang
like a simple expression of course it's
doing a gang so his uncle over saw him
getting jumped out so he didn't get hurt
that bad I don't have an uncle I
probably would've got killed and floated
that jumped out with him when I was 20
but now the white version of that is our
dad's the judge so we don't go to jail
or whatever the [ __ ] we just did your
version is yeah you got an uncle that
oversees being jumped out yeah I gotta
tell you dude I'm learning all kinds of
stuff like I want to I don't know why
case somebody's just walking by
somebody's recorder it's always feels
weird to have to like re-type something
so you're special on HBO you shot
yourself learning all of your
do-it-yourself stuff from [ __ ] going
around in those warehouses making
pillows out of nothing you ended up
shooting this at the The Improv in San
Jose which is one of my favorite great
club you feel like you're doing a
theater you know even though it's a club
it's tremendous and you shot it there
it's gonna be on HBO September 30th at
10:00 o'clock called translate this now
are you I know you're a great joke
writer but you I saw an Irish your fears
you told that they told the amazing
story that you you touched on today is
just stand up style in this more
joke-telling more storytelling or both
you know what my my comedy special is
it's more about um it's more about how I
got to this country with my parents and
being a single father and being a
cheater but yeah I cheat a lot I get
caught cheating cheating all the time
I'm bad I can't help it
I love women I talk about getting caught
cheating cos I was caught cheating you
know um Burt both girls showed up to my
house oh God you know I mean yeah in a
man it was crazy and they asked me we're
gonna say for yourself how's it made how
long was that beatdown was that long
about 18 seconds it was crazy
they showed up in the same bar was it
you all they talked to each other yeah
man
well now they film it and [ __ ] and then
you go in there and then you got to do
like an apology
[ __ ] the first 48 yeah Wow
okay so you're gonna do it I can't wait
to see this but I'll miss you okay I
really honestly do as a stand-up
comedian I cannot wait to see this think
you're one of the most interesting dudes
how are you so [ __ ] happy-go-lucky I
don't get it I don't know imagine love
life you know I'm never I'm never gonna
go back to that type of lifestyle that I
had in my 20s and I just love living
life man and I'm not gonna say that I'm
perfect because I did fall off the I was
well after I went to rehab I was sober
for 11 years like I didn't charge no
drugs I don't trust no alcohol no beer
and nothing but I'm along the way you
know that the more that this kind of
comedy the more you know I did it I'm
not going nowhere I went back to smoking
crack he went right back to crack mm-hmm
so you never really were a booze guy huh
no it's probably gonna boost my man's
got ease they do it's like Ralphie May
retweeted my tweet the other night and I
don't understand what he meant at first
because I was in Houston and he
retweeted watch out for those pools bro
and then I what the hell is rough we
were talking about them spoons then I
said oh [ __ ] bird I got soul it's poked
out in Houston Texas
i i ain't known for that yeah i couldn't
do no more coke because my nose were
bleeding so i wanted to rock it up and
smoke it in crack instead you know
because i wanted oh so you're just like
I'm just gonna snort a couple of lines
yeah what did you did you anticipate
like you like [ __ ] this when I go to
Houston I'm gonna party or it was was it
just a spontaneous thing and all of a
sudden you just said [ __ ] it
oh man just I was over there working the
laughs stop in Houston shout-out to Pete
always booking me Pete and I'm from the
laptop I got I started party man I
started partying and I couldn't find no
powder no coke
so I'm hope you don't mind me telling
this but I called Joe Diaz I say Joe
deal you know anybody over here you
caught him at 6:00 in the morning
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I know somebody
so I I knew he knew somebody I know that
um he go talk to this comedian so I
spoke to his comedian and then I'm this
little Mexican food showed up all week
taking care of me I gave him free
tickets every day I thank you and I I
don't know what happened man but I I did
too much coke and I felt like I can't do
no more go through my nose you know
started gonna go bad I want a smoke
crack now you know what I mean I don't
want steak I want burgers now dude a
reoccurring story with you is I don't
know what happened last time you didn't
know what happened you were whipping
somebody with the belt now you don't
know what happened it's like a [ __ ]
hole in your nose
Jesus well how long ago was this they
told them 2006 all right see ok 2007 so
you broke your record you've gone you've
come to Levin yeah yeah I called up room
service - the one it's more cracked and
I caught a Cavalier a collar room
service and it's a room service I'm
gonna need I'm a big spoon and a baking
soda brought over right now and they did
not bring that to the room oh they
brought it man they did two guys brought
it
the governor front dead he knew me cuz I
made friends with him already know from
previous times and he brought it you
know like a big spoon and he brought Arm
and Hammer baking soda and the guy with
him he just was with him to laugh at me
I guess he goes hey I guess you couldn't
believe it you know this guy just order
baking soda and spoon no way let's go
see so the Pope open the door like they
Hekla give it to me and they both laugh
but yeah man I wanted to smoke crack
okay so and and then and then how long
were you off the wagon for from when
okay so you're sober for 11 years you go
to Houston you order a spoon and some
baking soda now you snort coke now
you're smoking I got you partied that
weekend did you just come back and go
what the [ __ ] was that and were you able
to order you have to go rehab no man
I continue party man from that moment on
and the girl I will with man she in
there being a hermaphrodite but that was
another story for another time you know
but yeah she was a hermaphrodite she was
born with a penis in a vagina right so
like how long will she your girlfriend
before you figure that out
well we're part of it three nights you
must be a gentleman I didn't want to
touch her or nothing because she's brown
freak old man I can be that guy so I
just kissed her a couple of times but
then by the third night you know we were
out for three nights to raid her a night
but when I finally found out I was like
whoa man yeah that's a big skin tag you
got there so is that enough so was that
enough to get you sober again no man I
think it's over again too - you know
that stop sign all right so now we're
still going I think it over to 2009 oh
[ __ ] I was and you were already doing so
during those periods she was still doing
stand-up and you were doing stand-up I
would even know I even now got to go to
Montreal Comedy Festival in 2005 and I
was bad I did the young comedian show
and I did well I guess I did well I got
a little a little print on The Hollywood
Reporter I got an agent UTA actually
yeah they didn't have any idea you were
high no man I was like I was smoking
crack in Montreal - I hooked it up I
mean I found crack in Montreal it's
funny I I saw a Mexican guy in Montreal
and I knew he spoke Spanish and I told
him in how did you tell I just could
tell man he had the boots you know he
had that look like I need a job you know
you know that means it's hilarious he
got the boots you know he had that look
like okay I just got here cross-country
so he spoke Spanish he spoke Spanish no
English but he know he knows how to
speak French now but with a Mexican you
know Mexican accent he's doing all the
romantic languages
there's a double-walled uh and it gives
back Romance languages yeah man crag
well alright dude you are I could talk
to you for like [ __ ] ten hours and
you just don't run out it's amazing man
I don't know thank god you're still here
I'm sober no I know but all this stuff
you've done you know like realistically
you probably could have died in 80% of
the stories you just man I'm little
alive yeah I am two men because I think
you're a [ __ ] amazing comedian and
person I'm psyched that you're on the
all things comedy podcasts network with
the what's up fool podcast I wish you
nothing but the best with your your
stand-up special HBO Saturday September
30th set your DVRs whatever the kids do
now your cord cutters whatever you do to
[ __ ] see this thing and more success
to you and stay out of Houston I will
war so boo all right thanks Felipe
thanks bill burr Billy Berg all right
that was Felipe Esparza man that [ __ ]
guy who's amazing please check out a
special I just said all that [ __ ] I got
to do my reads here and then I'm going
to talk a little NFL football maybe
answer a couple of questions fill out
the rest of this hour here all right our
first oh Jesus look who's back it's all
zip up talk about the challenge of
finding I'm not doing that with zip
recruiter you can post your job to 100
100 plus job sites with just one click
then they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else that is
why that is why that's why zip cooter is
different unlike any other site zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them in fact eighty
percent of employees who post jobs unzip
get a quality candidate through the site
within one day no more juggling emails
you don't have time for that [ __ ] or
calls to your office simply screen rate
manage candidates all in one place that
zip recruit is easy to use dashboard
find out today why zip has been used by
businesses of all sizes
I'm the most quality job candidates with
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right free just go to
zip recruit comm / borough that zip
recruit accom / burg one more time for
free go to zip cruder dot-com / /
alright MVM tea also known as movement
the company that started what was
started by two broke college kids that
wanted to wear stylish watches but
couldn't afford them they had no money
and somehow they started a watch company
so they started their own watch company
how is this like how you started well I
didn't have any money and I then I
started a comedy club I built my career
now [ __ ] it I gotta come up with like a
metaphor here movement watches start at
just $95 at a department store you're
looking at four to five hundred bucks
and that's why people steal no more
shoplifting or boosting whatever your
people call you movement figured out
that by selling online they were able to
cut out the middleman and retail markup
providing the best possible experience
over 1 million watch is sold in over 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement watches calm that's MVM
t-dot-com / / this watch has a really
clean design seriously I've been getting
compliments and not just on my eyes
they're talking about the watch now is
the time to step up your watch game go
to MVM t-dot-com / / join the movement
and lastly but certainly not least lee
stamps.com
the cornerstone of this podcasts
advertisement avoid the hassle man of
the post office and mail everything from
postcards to envelope to packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account in just minutes online
with no equipment to lease and no
long-term commitments click print mail
and you're done unlike the post office
stamps calm never closes print postage
for lettuce or packages at your
convenience 24/7
/ descriptors I guess I'm supposed to
say this it's convenient it's easy its
reliable it's flexible right just like
your side piece there sorry I use stamps
calm because I always whenever I sell
posters at the end of my show when I
want to go out there and shake sweaty
hands you know and I need to send out my
posters I use stamps calm and I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure it out so can you
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bird that stamps
comm enter bird one more time Hey
stamps.com never go to the post office
again alright that's it okay stomach is
growling here I'm still on my [ __ ]
diet Oh Billie diet some [ __ ] [ __ ]
sent me a tweet going like you are
obsessed with your [ __ ] weight you
look fine get help it's like dude that's
why I look fine you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't give a [ __ ] your potato skins
eaten fat [ __ ] these guys with your
thick [ __ ] torsos you know what I
mean making that noise when you reach
back to get the seat belt trying to pull
it around you running out of material I
don't want to be that guy you know what
I mean that guy who gets killed by his
airbag because his fat face is too close
to the geeks miniature explosion anyways
all things comedy festival by the way
podcast festival October twenty six
twenty seven twenty eighth twenty ninth
in Phoenix ticket links at billboard.com
by the way I am going to do my first
ever live Monday morning podcast there
at this stand-up live comedy club I'm
gonna do it live I'll do it live and I'm
gonna do it just how I do it my [ __ ]
house alright I thought about getting a
guest and I was like [ __ ] dad that's not
the jam of what it is that I do so I'm
just gonna do it I don't know what I'll
lay down on the stage I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm gonna do but I'm gonna do
it the exact way I do so if you ever
wanted to see this [ __ ] live this
absolute train wreck if you wanted to
see what it looked like in real time
come on down to the stand-up live comedy
club in Phoenix Arizona October 28th I
will be there I don't know when tickets
go on sale
Leon I guess they're on sales now their
own ticket links are at billboard.com
there you go all right
anyways let's talk some NFL football ooh
baby did you guys enjoy it did you team
when my team won the New England
Patriots who everybody said was going to
go undefeated and then we lost to the
Kansas City Chiefs and then everybody
said oh wait a minute wait a minute
I think Tom Brady is old now I think
he's washed up I think the Kansas City
Chiefs are gonna win their first Super
Bowl since 1970 that's what everybody
said because the Kansas City Chiefs beat
the New England Patriots in September
now all of a sudden they can see January
how [ __ ] crazy is that how many
[ __ ] times how many times you gonna
watch the Giants go Owen - when Owen
three and just start writing them off
you saw the points they scored huh you
think they're not gonna come back and
beat Philly they're not gonna come back
and beat Dallas later on this [ __ ]
year when they all get on the same page
they were protecting Eli much better
according to the 30 seconds of
highlights that I saw I'm sticking by my
prediction New England Patriots New York
Giants Super Bowl rematch alright until
the Kansas City Chiefs who I actually
like until who Andy Reid who I'm not
saying he's fat until those [ __ ] do
something in January all right I think
all you need to sit down a little bit
and [ __ ] relax with all your [ __ ]
talking how many [ __ ] guys have you
seen throw for 500 yards in the regular
season and get bounced out in the first
round of the playoffs how many times did
you see a [ __ ] guys zigzagging all
over the field you can't tackle him and
come playoff time he's sitting on a
[ __ ] exercise bike where Ana tinted
windshield across his eyes huh the
incredible lack of [ __ ] respect that
you gave our little quarterback that
could Tom Brady how dare you how dare
you write off the New England Patriots
after one [ __ ] week huh it's all
wishful thinking
we're coming again and we're gonna take
your hearts out and we're gonna pull
them out of your chest we're gonna show
them to you and then we're gonna under
inflate them on our way to another
[ __ ] actually we never
I can't doing that they just suggested
that we did it and it got laughed out of
court and then do what I really need to
address the stupid controversy of the
[ __ ] people taking a knee during the
national anthem you know watching all
these white people getting [ __ ] upset
by that like it real does it really
affect your [ __ ] life and all these
[ __ ] idiots trying to make the point
of what they're doing it's not about
your point the people who started this
thing it's about my point it's about the
way that I see it you know I had a buddy
of mine go yeah these [ __ ] guys they
make a million dollars you know he think
it's bad here why don't you go [ __ ]
move to Syria it's like why do they have
to move why can't they just live here
the way you do I don't understand that
and but Donald Trump is a [ __ ] genius
that he has everybody talking about this
issue cuz he is trying to get everybody
to stop focusing on the pool party he
had with [ __ ] Vladimir
what's-his-face over there in Russia he
doesn't want you watching that he goes
oh look at this over here right he goes
down to Alabama and he gets all them
[ __ ] people all riled up and he keeps
talking about this fatty over in [ __ ]
North Korea that's what he's doing it
reminds me of when oh [ __ ] Slick
Willy
you know bombed that country cuz he
stuck his cigar in that woman's another
region this is the type of sick people
that become president this is what they
do all right they get caught doing some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and then I will say this
about Trump least he didn't go bomb some
people unlike what's-his-face with his
[ __ ] hands who now gets treated like a
[ __ ] hero I don't understand that guy
at all you know what I mean
oh that's great yeah I got caught
getting my dick sucked in the Oval
Office so I bombed the country I might
have killed the baby but I sleep like
whatever not um I know I'm a conspiracy
theorist I [ __ ] hate them all did you
see that thing what's-his-face and
[ __ ] Korea considered that we
declared war on him right so uh Maggie
Maggie Hall whatever [ __ ] name is
Maggie Gyllenhaal what is it what is the
[ __ ] the poor woman who has to go out
and [ __ ] give the press conferences
now because that dude with no neck
you know who kind of looks like the
political version of Roger Goodell went
out there and [ __ ] it all up the
hell's her name she's got a classic
political name I don't know what the
hell it is she said the fact that North
Korea thinks that we're at war with them
is absolutely preposterous or something
like that and then like a week before
what's-his-face
Trump basically tweeted like that that
fatty over there wasn't long for this
earth and it's like he kind of just said
he's not gonna last he's not gonna be
around long that's what he said yeah I
mean I would take that as a threat I'll
have a - first have a - you know what
they really need to do they both need to
just go to a [ __ ] house together and
[ __ ] grow up you know bang a couple
of [ __ ] they need to do with threesome
right
one of them's getting blown the others
hit in a doggy style and just their eyes
meet they just start laughing being like
this is a great life right you got a
personal chef - yeah that's [ __ ]
amazing you live in a castle live in a
White House and they it's [ __ ] it's
cool they should just talk about you
know trade stories the way comedians
trade stories about bombing they could
just talk about [ __ ] bomb in other
countries and I don't know what fishing
whatever whatever people at that level
talk about all right let's get to the
questions for this week so I don't have
any [ __ ] problem
with these these guys taken a knee I try
to listen to what it's about rather than
getting wrapped up in what what what it
means to me pharmacist writing in dear
Billy bag chaser I don't know what that
means by the way people 39 days sober 39
[ __ ] days and this is this is how
well I'm doing with my sobriety when I
flew to Canada I went by this duty-free
and there's this McCallum rare cast they
got this new one black oak or some [ __ ]
like that I was like I'm gonna buy that
okay I'm not gonna take it to [ __ ]
Canada then suck it down like a [ __ ]
jackass I'm just gonna have this thing
waiting for me you know what I mean for
whenever I fall off the wagon so this is
like what I was thinking the whole ride
in and like you know I'm getting off the
plane
I'm trying to beat the crowd to get over
to the taxi line cuz I don't [ __ ]
over and I never remember to set up a
car so I always go to the [ __ ] taxi
line what's great at LAX is is that
anybody there cuz nobody [ __ ] takes a
taxi ever he's got a friend to pick him
up I don't know what the [ __ ] they do
there's always plenty of cabs so I don't
even try to be first in line at the
capstan I go out of my way over to this
duty-free place and I grab this [ __ ]
thing
you know and I just like bring it up to
the counter and the lady goes oh my god
she goes [ __ ] what a wonderful choice
and blah blah blah blah blah you have
great taste like I am I go I'm on the
wagon when I come off this is the bottle
I'm opening up she goes are you going to
Canada I said nope I'm going home and
she goes oh I'm sorry I can't sell you
this and like why not she goes you have
to be going to can is something about
the duty-free and I'm like it's it's
legal though do they sell this anywhere
else in the airport if you're just going
back to your home they're like no no we
don't so I don't know so I had a [ __ ]
hissy fit I had a [ __ ] hissy fit I to
hissy fits one of the way they're going
through Canadian customs when they made
me take the de lime-green plastic cover
off of my [ __ ] laptop like I somehow
had a bomb in there or some sort of bomb
residue and I'm literally taking it off
going I'm gonna crack this thing and
they go well just try to take it off
easily it's like would you look I look
like [ __ ] Howdy Doody what I'm in
this matrix I like what's going on tell
me what you want me to do the [ __ ] so
they make me take that [ __ ] thing off
ended up cracking the cover so I'm are
in a bad mood so rather than you know
growing up and realizing that these
[ __ ] people that was it that the TCA
TCP whatever [ __ ] it took care to yeah
what is it called TSA the [ __ ] TSA
rather than just realizing these people
are trying to protect me which I don't
think they're trying to do I think
they're trying to make it as
inconvenient as [ __ ] possible so I'll
agree to have my [ __ ] retina scan so
they can share that [ __ ] information
and gradually build a [ __ ] robot
sorry
and put this [ __ ] headphones back um
yeah so all I wanted was a bottle of
booze that's all I wanted and they
wouldn't sell it to me they wouldn't
sell it to me so I went online uh I'll
figure out a [ __ ] place to get it
alright let's let's do the little right
in here pharmacist writing in dear Billy
bag chaser your rant on pharmacist last
week was hilarious we have to be able
able to laugh at ourselves right
I just wanted to weigh in on a couple of
things first off the medication you were
prescribed the anti-inflammatory drug
you received was in the non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug class how the
[ __ ] do you know you didn't even look at
it maybe you just be I know that I could
tell just by the way he's talking about
it I understand
basically these drugs decrease the
formation of prostaglandins and
thromboxane those chemicals are involved
in the inflammation process which itself
causes pain so these drugs can't just
decrease inflammation without also
decreasing pain thus being labeled a
painkiller okay
NSAIDs are not in the opioid family okay
are not happy for habit-forming I don't
know what this guy is talking about but
it sounds like he's blowing my argument
out of the water however they can be
very dangerous in susceptible
populations why can't just say with
addicts susceptible populations you guys
are such [ __ ] creeps in that world
NSAIDs NSAIDs and SEDs increase the risk
of cardiac events kidney damage and
stomach ulcers also recovered addicts
usually in the elderly or those with
pre-existing conditions I'm not sure
what the other drug you received was if
it was a narcotic opioid painkiller and
the doctrine pharmacists did not discuss
it with you they would be negligible on
their parts since when since when I want
to know now that the the [ __ ] heroin
epidemic is completely out of control in
the state of Ohio is suing
pharmaceutical companies I guarantee I
graduated four years ago and the dangers
of narcotics was extremely stressed
all the medical bodies are communicating
the dangers of narcotics to
practitioners and overseeing that
prescribing is done appropriately and
maybe this is just a [ __ ] it's just
how we are you know like when we first
they first had that DDT and they sprayed
it all over the place and this is like
great we just ended all these plagues
and then we did all this damage to the
environment we created this [ __ ]
window that is starting to close I feel
where it was this Golden Age of not
having to walk around with the [ __ ]
boil on your face and dying of the Black
Plague and we just got a little out of
control with it which would have been
great is if as we eradicated all of
these different diseases if we somehow
didn't grow the population I feel like
that's the sweet spot I feel like that's
what the [ __ ] Illuminati should be
discussing is like what is the optimal
number of people including ourselves of
course who should be allowed to survive
while we keep all the modern day
technologies so we can still live this
awesome flat screen life with no plagues
but like we also can still sustain like
living on this [ __ ] planet what is
that thing what is what is that number
and they're not taking College because
they're a [ __ ] closed entity all
right let me read a few more of these
well how much time are we up to at this
point 18 minutes plus 37 is 55 okay all
right so here we go gold money.com dear
Billy copper nuts I heard you talk about
gold money.com
on your pot Monday morning podcast who
have you emailed you about it didn't
explain it very well I feel like all
these are just like free commercials I
haven't put any money into it yet but
now I'm gonna speak about it as an
authority but I am considering it as it
seems pretty legit if you listen to
Rogen's podcast with Peter Schiff he
explains it pretty well and makes a good
pitch yeah but that guide stands to
profit off it granted Schiff admits that
he invested money in the company yeah so
he's out he's out I want an independent
[ __ ] debtor I can even find that
anymore
evidently they sell you the gold at a
low market price half of 1% I think
what do you mean half of 1% of what
that's just sort of a number floating
out there right stored for you in a
vault if you're choosing with your name
on it if you want it they will actually
mail your goal to you for free
minimum of like five grams or something
you also get a MasterCard debit card
that you can use to spend your gold
slash money evidently you can use you
can even get a debit card that is made
of real gold which sounds [ __ ] baller
the Federal Reserve and powers that may
be may never let it work but it seems
like a great idea at least thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah there's a bunch of
great ideas yeah I'm all set on that
yeah you give me your cash and we'll put
it in gold in a vault that you choose
that's not where you can see it
all right dating in Saudi Arabia now
maybe I don't know it sounds like even
if their their mind is in the right
place it's gonna go belly-up and then
they're all gonna write themselves
bonuses off your gold that's what I
would guess what happened or the Federal
Reserve will come and say this is all
illegal and take all the gold and then
act like it's in Fort Knox when it's
really [ __ ] I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is somewhere in the
Hamptons
all right dating in Saudi Arabia hey
there Billy Billy the pie maker hope
you're having a great day anyways I
wanted your advice on this problematic
[ __ ] that I'm stuck in I met this lady
through a common friend of ours Oh God
we talked and this is nothing's gonna
get messy when you break up with her
then you're gonna lose her and a friend
we talked she's really cool person we
got a lot of things in common then we
met again twice as a friend and now I
want to ask her out but here's the thing
she is Egyptian and I'm Indian and we
live in Saudi Arabia
Rabia and dating is illegal here well
then what the [ __ ] did you go out with
there for now your hearts gonna get
cause you two get you [ __ ] what do
they do of that beat your feet in the
square they're gonna [ __ ] slap your
dick around in public or something
whatever the punishment is over there I
mean the authority could deport you
immediately or worse send you to jail
for years now I really like this girl
more than you freedom
all right now I really like this girl
and I like you not even love this girl
and I've already thought of of names for
our kids before she even said yes to me
but I'm really stuck on thinking through
my brain okay this is second language
here I'm gonna try to help this out here
but I'm really stuck here what should I
stink through my brain or through my
dick should I uh well do none of that is
your heart so you should just leave
should I ask her out and open for a
whole nother level of problems or said I
just shut the [ __ ] up any advice from
you is highly appreciated love the
podcast and love you as a brother go
[ __ ] yourself there's not a woman or a
man out there worth going to [ __ ]
prison in Saudi Arabia I know how bad
the prisons are over here I don't know
what they like over there you guys got a
lot of oil money although I did running
into this guy from Saudi Arabian who's
laughing his ass off for me go dude we
don't we don't all have oil money and I
was a sec alright fair enough there's
oil man over here I don't have any that
money yeah do it I would walk away from
this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] illegal you could
go to jail you get deported you don't I
mean and even if you love somebody
they're gonna annoy the [ __ ] out of you
so I mean is that worth going to jail
for you know I don't is it illegal to
just bang her but then if you love her I
don't know I don't know I I would I
would get out of that I get out of it
alright alright great movie scene
unknown actor alright oh yeah I was
talking about this is the this is a new
topic here where I was talking about
actors that you saw just do like five
lines in a [ __ ] movie and they
absolutely destroyed it and you and your
friends still quote them you don't even
know their [ __ ] names I brought up
that guy last week the guy from pulp
reservoir dogs' the guy in you know when
Tim Roth's character is uh what is he
he's in the [ __ ] bathroom that cops
telling that story I said buddy I am
gonna shoot you in the face you know put
your [ __ ] hands in that dashboard
love that guy
so here he goes one of my favorite
scenes with an unknown actor was Kill
Bill 2 bills brother bud I wish I need
to see these movies to do this justice I
mean I saw this but I don't remember it
she she wore the same out
that [ __ ] yellow outfit both movies
than she bills brother bud is working as
a bouncer and a rundown strip club he
shows up late for work gets called into
his boss's office his boss Larry Gomez
is played by actor Larry Bishop and he
looks like half a wolf man after doing a
line of blow with a haggard looking
stripper oh I vaguely remember this he
levels his gaze at buzz and bud and says
I don't know what carwash you worked
before you came here that let you stroll
in 20 minutes late
but it wasn't owned by you but it wasn't
owned by me and I own a [ __ ] carwash
I just butchered that line people I
can't realized that I need glasses and I
have slight dyslexia like I was trying
to write squawk today and I knew all the
letters I just could not remember so I
was trying to remember what's squawking
7700 versus 7,500 I always get those two
mixed up if that's an emergency landing
or a [ __ ] hijacking I was because one
stay alive and the other is [ __ ] go
to heaven all right sorry that's how you
remember it 75 stay alive 77 go to
heaven all right 75 is hijacking 77 is
emergency and 76 need a fix means your
[ __ ] radios out this doesn't mean
anything to you guys I don't know what
carwash you work before you came here
that let you stroll in 20 minutes late
but it wasn't owned by me and I own a
[ __ ] carwash there you go that was a
good [ __ ] read that makes me want to
go see that movie he said he then
proceeded to give this world-class
assassin a humiliating dress-down
telling him he's as useless as an
[ __ ] on his elbow and crossing off
all his scheduled work days on the
calendar he finishes by telling him
never to wear his cowboy hat to work and
has him cleaned a clogged toilet on his
way out all bud can do is stand there
and take it I hope you've seen this
great movie if not it's worth to watch
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself I'm gonna go
watch it again all right I think i'ma
think this bit is gonna make people go
see these cool movies again and it's
also gonna make everybody laugh at how
bad I can't [ __ ] read out loud all
right bill my favorite line in a comedy
ever it might be from Blazing Saddles
delivered by slim pick
he rides into the scene where his
workers are singing camp is it camptown
races always always camp camptown races
and says what in the wide wide world a
sport is going on here
I heard you people to try to get I had
you people to try to get a little track
laid not to jump around like a bunch of
Kansas City [ __ ]
I remember that line whatever the hell
that means and I'm quoting a movie by
the way before everybody gets all
[ __ ] uptight about that you know
Richard Pryor wrote on that and he was
actually supposed to be the lead in it
and then they went with the the other
actor and I don't know any actors names
okay three number three bill you asked
for movie lines said by a non movie star
actress that your listeners friends
talked about for my group of friends
it's a line from ghostbusters when Peter
Venkman
Bill Murray shows up to Dana's W Weaver
apartment right after the dog monster
runs loose from Lewis tell you I've
never seen that movie I've never seen
Ghostbusters just not a sci-fi guy think
is that considered sci-fi Venkman shows
up to the scene and asks a cop what
happened and the cop nonchalantly
replies some [ __ ] brought a cougar to a
party and it went berserk my friends and
I have been quoting that cop for years
check it out at 2:30 of the falling oh I
can I can look at these [ __ ] I can click
on the links this is even better why
have me read it when I can click on the
links all right we'll compare my read
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] kind of link
he is sending me here I thought that was
gonna go to your [ __ ] yeah boy oh boy
am I gonna have to have an apology video
here what the [ __ ] just happened
let's do I do this other one this is
Mike all right [ __ ] all these things
these things are gonna be too long and
evidently they they have the n-word in
them yeah boy do I need to take a knee
after this one all right number four I
have to unknown and unheralded actors
with memorable movie lines both are the
great Mel Brooks movies the first one is
the Roman soldier in the history of the
world part one the Empress is
approaching but the there's a horse and
a carriage in the way the Roman soldier
looks directly at the camera and says
move that miserable piece of [ __ ]
the over-the-top Way delivers the line
comes out of nowhere I say it all the
time and then the best impression I can
do you know what I got to do I have to
get the actual clips for this to work
because what I'm now doing is ruining
I'm ruining great movies all right
girlfriend believes in ghosts all right
girlfriend believes in ghosts dear
Grandmaster B I met this lady a few
weeks ago things went really good she's
very cool I found her good-looking and
we have a lot of stuff to talk about I
didn't have a great a lot of I didn't
have a lot of relationships in the past
I'm 32 and I picked up my game about
four years ago everything was great
until we went to a restaurant one day
and she told me she believes in ghosts
not just that she said she actually sees
them and even got patients who come to
her for treatment about it I tried to be
open-minded about it oh my god I can
just hear the silverware hitting the
plates at this point trying to compare
it to people who believe in God but her
believing in this keeps bugging me I'm
not saying she's crazy or wrong Who am I
to know but she doesn't sit right the
way I see the world well then [ __ ]
drop her this is the thing now this is
whole [ __ ] straight across the board
you have to look at everything like all
the leaves are brown and the sky is gray
like if you're dating and somebody does
something and it makes your buddy you
just body literally go like what the
[ __ ] and then you're literally you're
gonna fight that feeling and go well
maybe I need to stop being so ghosts of
phobic it's
no it's [ __ ] ghosts it's weird you
know you're gonna [ __ ] live with
Whoopi Goldberg's character from ghost
that's what you're gonna do people
trying to sit on her and [ __ ] trying to
sit on your wife that's what you're
gonna sign up for me if that's what
you're into by all means do it but if
you're on a date and that there's like
that's a major [ __ ] thing because
it's not like she just believes in and
every once in a while she's gonna hear
like a thump in the house and start
telling you it's a ghost when you're
like honey it's [ __ ] air in the pipes
all right we just have to [ __ ] turn
on the faucet
you know you know remember the plumber
did work today and they shut it off for
a second that that's what that is you
know that's not that she actually she's
gonna become like a ghost hunter and all
of that stuff and gradually she's gonna
get starts dressing more and more like
she can predict the future and you don't
want to [ __ ] that you know what I mean
when they start wearing those long
flowing things you know just you just so
many layers of clothes to try to pick up
to just get it going you know you start
wearing like curtains and [ __ ] you don't
need that anyways all right um sorry
that whole [ __ ] movie thing just I
don't know can you guys just send me the
goddamn clip I guess you sent me the
clip what I should have done was queue
it up I tried to do too many things I
tried to promote [ __ ] I try to do all
that and then do the whole thing the
whole [ __ ] thing just fell apart
alright let me just finish with this
last thing a buddy of mine is opening a
[ __ ] a new comedy club on the Upper
West Side in Manhattan okay
Friday October 6 and October 7th it's
like a little 100-seat [ __ ] Club I'm
gonna be coming to town in November and
I'm gonna pop in and do a spot I love
little clubs like that
let's see here Russman Eve's gonna be
there Greer Barnes mark Norman John
Fisher rod small Brian Scott McFadden
and many more it's gonna be a great show
if you're on the Upper East Side I'm up
West Side sorry it's on 201 West 75th
streets right next to the Beacon Theater
which is also cool you know what I mean
you go in there and you [ __ ] do your
spots and you come out and you go wow
someday
I'll be across the street it's
tremendous give it a shot if you're in
town Friday October 6 in October 7th I
got the hiccup
that's the podcast please check out
Felipe as far as his new stand-up
special what's it called translate this
September 30th on HBO 10:00 p.m. it
feels more like indigestion I have any
meeting today all right go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday